[Music]
this kind of an image is not new to us
especially for people who love forensic
science but what exactly is this it's an
image of the separated DNA fragments on
a piece of gel and the process of
separating them is called gel
electrophoresis doesn't the sound very
difficult separating DNA fragments on a
piece of gel but actually the process of
gel electrophoresis is not very
difficult in fact it's quite easy let's
have a look at how the process works and
also the principle behind it let's begin
with the definition first gel
electrophoresis is a technique to
separate the different DNA molecules
based on their sizes can you guess why
is it called gel electrophoresis okay
let me help you with this this
separation technique is based on the
movement of charged molecules when
exposed to an electrical field and this
movement occurs in a gel medium hence
it's known as gel electrophoresis now
let's understand the process step by
step but before that since the term
charge is used by us here can you guess
the charge present on a DNA molecule
let me tell you that a DNA is negatively
charged and this is due to the presence
of phosphate groups these phosphate
being negatively charged and present in
the backbone of the DNA double helix
impart a negative charge to the complete
molecule and what is the gel used
interestingly the gel which is generally
used for the DNA is agarose gel and it's
obtained from the seaweeds now getting
back to a process we said that the DNA
molecules get separated on the basis of
their sizes so if we have a sample of
DNA which is containing fragments formed
with the activity of restriction enzymes
then separating the fragments based on
the difference in their sizes would be
possible with gel electrophoresis
let's have a look at this in detail do
you understand the principle and working
let's take the analogy of a sieve we
note that if a mixture of different
sized particles is poured onto a sieve
then only the particles smaller in size
than the pores will escape while those
bigger in size will be retained back
here the size of the particles is the
only parameter used for the separation
same is the case with DNA fragments when
our DNA sample containing various sized
fragments is loaded onto a gel then the
charge applied across the gel helps in
the mobility of these fragments however
not all fragments move at the same pace
those which are smaller move ahead and
those which are larger in size find it
difficult to move to understand this
better let's zoom into the gel that is
prepared for the experiment here at the
microscopic level we find that the gel
appears to be a mesh-like structure and
the pore size is nearly constant
throughout so now imagine what will
happen if different sized DNA fragments
are made to pass through these pores
it's obvious that the small sized
fragments will escape the pores faster
while the larger fragments will find it
difficult to come out they will take a
lot of time to cross the smaller pores
and dust will lag behind this is how we
can understand the principle of
separation of the DNA fragments based on
their sizes now let's see how the
procedure works the first requirement is
the complete set up this will include
the casting tray gel a comb for making
wells in the gel electric supply and
most importantly DNA sample with
different sized DNA fragments here's an
illustration of the casting tray
containing the gel in which we will load
the DNA mixture we usually opt for a
comb to form well like structures into
the gel and why do we do that because
it's in these worlds in the agarose gel
that we load the DNA mixture now tell me
where should the wells be formed at the
ends or at the centre think about it
we know that the DNA fragments being
negatively charged will travel from a
point of negative charge to the point of
positive charge
does we need to form the wells to load
the DNA samples near the negative
terminal or the cathode to be precise so
that the DNA will move towards the
positively charged anode this movement
of the DNA molecule will be promoted by
the electric field but we cannot track
the movement of the DNA in the gel as
it's colorless for this we use a colored
loading dye to track the movement of the
DNA the mixture of the DNA samples with
the colored loading dye is now all set
to get into the gel but before loading
the DNA mixture we will fill the
apparatus with a buffer as shown
the buffer is used to provide better
conductivity of electricity next we will
load the DNA mixture into the wells and
we're ready to turn on the power supply
once the power supply is turned on the
DNA mixture will move through the gel
which can be tracked with the help of
the loading dye the loading dye is
selected in such a way that it travels a
bit faster than the DNA segments present
in the mixture and why is that so that's
because we want the loading dye to reach
the terminal end faster than the DNA
once the dye reaches the anode we get an
indication that the DNA must have
reached somewhere near and does the
power supply has to be turned off
moving ahead with the next step now we
know that the DNA molecules have got
separated but can we really see them no
that's not possible so how will that be
possible now how do we observe the
separated segments to observe the DNA
molecules we treat the agarose gel with
helium bromide solution the major reason
for using ethidium bromide is that it
easily binds to the DNA molecules and
when the agarose gel containing the DNA
is observed under ultraviolet light
bright orange colored bands are clearly
seen these are nothing but the bands of
the DNA the separation has been
successful based on the size of the DNA
fragments the larger molecule are the
ones found here which means these are
the ones that moved slowly on the other
hand the smaller molecules which moved
faster are the ones
spotted here now how do we know the size
of any DNA fragment the bands obtained
are compared with a standard chart known
as the DNA ladders on comparing the
positions of the bands with the ones
from the chart we can easily make out
the length of the fragments obtained
once we know the length of the fragments
we can easily identify the desired DNA
now the desired DNA fragment can be
first manually cut out from the agarose
gel and then extracted this process is
called illusion the extraction of the
DNA is done in such a way that it can be
used for further downstream processing
this was the simple explanation of how
any gel electrophoresis technique works
it's considered as one of the very
important techniques used in recombinant
DNA technology to learn more about such
interesting processes stay tuned to our
Channel and do not forget to subscribe
happy learning
you